you made a video called wind card games
break oh yeah where you got a lot I
can't wait
we're going there right now right off
page and you told me you can't talk
about it yeah let's talk about okay
I wouldn't even I wouldn't phrase it as
what rule does it play in my life it
defines everything about my life for the
second episode of coffee with we're
gonna jump right in
our guest is Austin McConnell who is a
filmmaker a real filmmaker as in he's
competed around the world in film
festivals but he's also a youtuber a
family man and so much more we're gonna
talk about what got Austin into
filmmaking whether the last Jedi is
actually a good movie how to handle a
hate when a community lashes out at you
how to find a great book and why you
should break the mold a little context
we met in a film festival in Orlando
Florida
in fact we spoke on a panel together and
I was just so impressed how great the
video sa youtuber community is off
camera but on camera I think you'll find
Austin is just charming all in all I
really enjoyed this interview and a
quick note the audio may be a bit
strange as one of the lab alia mics I
was using failed so I had to use a
secondary mic I apologize in advance but
especially as I'm learning to interview
people I expect I'll make plenty more
technical errors one last thing to
mention
I kept the interview a lot shorter this
time around let me know if you enjoy
that change and if you'd like to see
more videos kept short like this one so
here it is enjoy I'm really excited for
you welcome to the second edition of
coffee with we're here with Austin
McConnell filmmaker and as you can see
things have changed and the coffee with
production without all this I thought we
would address that right up you've got a
filmstrips you've got an Apple box with
coffee we are currently at the Orlando
Film Festival and they have graciously
decided to let us use a few of their
gadgets so we're super pumped about that
and you will see a return to the normal
budget production value shortly so
please enjoy this is like
this is amazing I'm shocked I wish that
the audience could see all of the work
that went in before people were running
around I just I we've got so many people
in the room to disappoint and we will
that's the point so I want to start your
your filmmaker and you've been a
filmmaker for a while
I know a lot of people in this space
kind of got into it they saw someone
else do it and they said oh I can I can
grab Premiere Pro I can do it myself on
a you know laptop you've been doing this
for a while and I wanted to ask you what
got you started what was your formative
moment in filmmaking where you realized
I want to be a filmmaker and I've wanted
series to take it seriously that's a
good question so I decided that I wanted
to become a filmmaker when I was
watching Return of the Jedi in theaters
as a kid and Luke Skywalker threw the
lightsaber away refusing to strike down
his strike down his father and the music
swelled and he's like never I'll never
never turn to the dark side I am a Jedi
like my father before me
second that music picked up I was like
all right I want to make movies that's
what I want to do this stuff is pretty
cool
obviously you're a huge Star Wars head
but I mean from judging by your catalog
you have a bunch of Star Wars films
about like kind of esoteric Star Wars
you know movies and you up in like
fiction and stuff like that so that was
the big breakout moment for you where
you said this is what I want to do I
want to make movies were you thinking
like like Star Wars you're just thinking
in this no man I mean it's just like one
of the reasons that Star Wars were so
good originally was that it was sort of
like the hero's journey and you know
that entire story cycle and it was in a
fun and exciting way what kid growing up
in that particular era didn't love Star
Wars I mean it like probably every
person in this room right now who says
stepfather was influenced in some way by
that and you know growing up I was a
nerdy kid that you know most folks in
YouTube are and I grew up loving Star
Wars
I was totally nerd it out for all the
some expanded universe stuff like that
and if you had told me that years later
I would be able to find success making
videos about obscure Star Wars planets
and aliens as an extension of successive
video I would have thought you were
crazy but so I had a follow-up question
of this and it requires an admission on
my part okay so I was not a huge I was a
Star Wars fan like everybody but I was
not very cat but you weren't like crazy
I would watch the movies and I thought
oh they're good but I never thought like
these are the movies to see these are
the movies to watch yeah I liked all the
wrong movies I liked like Clone Wars and
like Revenge of the Sith those I loved
the last Jedi I thought oh this is a
turn to win there right now right off
page in dislike Disney's turning the
page of stars I got out of the theater I
thought what a great movie I go to the
reviews yeah and it's split down the
middle I mean I have people who
absolutely think mmm it's a crime
against the whole Star Wars you know
catalogs yeah some people think it's
great yeah where do you a Star Wars
expert give us the definitive stuff I'm
gonna be there lower 30s Star Wars next
Star Wars expert speaks on I cannot give
a definitive opinion on a film as to how
you should think or feel about it but
what do you think I think the last Jedi
was great loved it I think that its
greatness is evidenced by the fact that
it is so divisive that sounds strange to
say but you're for the first time in a
long time they are experimenting with
the form of those stories in a way that
at least is eliciting a reaction from
people and in order for stories to stay
fresh and to explore new territory you
have to kind of go out to the weeds you
have to go out and do things that are a
little risky and that was a very risky
entry I was a fan of Rian Johnson's way
back when he released brick in 2005
which is really low budget affair and it
was interesting to see I was wondering
how he would translate that to
you know the platform with Star Wars and
uh you know I liked it I liked how it
experimented with the story and how it
took it kind of took a blowtorch to
certain expectations that people had
absolutely that's good films do not
exist to satisfy your fan theory because
one of the things is that like people
how should i phrase this when it comes
to any franchise any story people think
they know they know what they want but
what they need to hear or what they need
to see in a film is very rarely what
they want to see and if you're just
shooting for meeting people's
expectations
instead of transcending them then what's
the point yeah you see this all the time
in like music where everyone wants the
artist to say stay exactly the same yeah
and they're not willing to go over some
bumpy albums before they get to the next
thing that they love well the thing is
I've never gotten there without people
say man it's it's I wish that they would
go back to the way they were I wish this
would go back to the way that it was you
know way back when but it's like there
are other forms of media where people
did stay in that wheelhouse and it's the
ones that those are the things that you
stopped watching because it's just never
changed or anything like you know you've
got to when you tell stories you want to
experiment you want to play around and
try new things and sometimes it's a hit
sometimes it's a miss they're gonna be
rolling out Star Wars films way after
you and I have both died I mean there's
we're not gonna live to see the last
Star Wars film when Disney bought them
and it stopped being just the defined
trilogy or trilogies
and they said that they were just going
to make them from now on duty it's like
James Bond
I mean sometimes they releases a Bond
film and you go I was pretty good and
sometimes the Bond films releases like
yeah it's not bad but there'll be other
ones and you know you have to it's quite
interesting in that I'm some people view
me as this really hardcore Star Wars
nerd but at the same time you are a big
nerd I am I am a big nerd and a big Star
Wars nerd but I still am able to view it
with a level
you know okay it's not the it's about
the end of the world if they release a
bad film every now and then just get
them the next time the only place I draw
the line at is where people say you have
to think what I think you have to think
it's a bad movie or you have to think
it's a good movie the only thing that I
can say is to me it's a good movie if
you disagree they have fun at least
we're getting to Star Wars we can enjoy
it at least we're talking about new
stuff as opposed to rehashing the old
stuff
speaking of kind of you know working on
your own taste and not having taste as
everyone else I know you went into
making kind of independent movies for a
while and you were going to film
festivals I suspect that that probably
played a big role in how you tell
stories today is the lesson do you learn
back then so arrested especially I saw
something about you would do 48 hour
film festivals where you would have to
do a film from 48 hours and it's hard to
get anything done in 48 hours much less
you know shooting the video scripting I
mean it's a scripting - right
yeah dad had to be I mean I just imagine
that had to be huge for you learning how
to put something together on time you
know and you had to get it done yeah
well when I when I was a student we
would compete in these 48 hour film
challenges where you they give you a
prompt they say this is what the film
has to be about has to use this line of
dialogue and this prop and you've got
two days after two days bring it in and
that's that if you're two days in one
second over it doesn't get accepted and
so go and you've got to run off and
figure it all out in two days it reminds
me of those Jeff shows where they say
like you two agree exactly when do I
have to use the two ingredients and
maybe they don't work too well together
and you have to be creative yeah that's
exactly what it's like and the thing is
that there's no entry barrier to it you
just you know pay the ten buck or twenty
five feet and you get to compete and for
some people it's an excuse to go out
with some of their friends and make a
cheesy movie
and have a little bit of fun and that's
great for people who are aspiring to be
to work in the video TV video film space
it gives them an excuse to try it a lot
of people who compete especially for me
when I was competing in those challenges
I was a student I was still learning the
craft still learning how to operate
cameras and how to edit to mix and even
act you know and so I mean it gave me a
platform to try out the art of
filmmaking now the problem with that was
that those festivals only ran once a
year and so I was kind of at a point
where it was like okay I've got one shot
every year to make a movie and I wasn't
doing much of anything else it wasn't
till after I started doing YouTube to
where I was able to use the principles
that I learned in 48 hour film making
and apply it to you know something like
YouTube you know YouTube is very fast
paced you have a quick turnaround time
for putting content out and it's like
any other muscle when I first started
out doing YouTube I had not really been
in the creative gym pumping the iron so
to speak and so it took a while for me
to lift the heavy weights and so I had
to start with the smaller weights you
know maybe release one video online and
it got to the point where I could do
that and it's time to up the weights and
it's time to do twice a month and I'm
kind of at the point now where I can for
the most part get out one a week and you
know sometimes it's sometimes I miss a
week and so I do too the next week or
you know I try to do for a month
basically and the more I've done that
the easier to been able to do and you
know the first time I started doing it
one a week the videos weren't as good
quality but once you kind of learn the
workload you get to increase the
increase the quality of the product that
you're putting out so to connect these
ideas with like the arc as you came to
where you are today
seems like you you watched our words
want to be a filmmaker then you did
these 48-hour challenges but that was
all in the film direction and what you
do today is not exactly that it's kind
of a hybrid of ensuring the next
evolution of video essays yeah
what was that moment because I can't
imagine you saw yourself on YouTube
where like making the kinds of movies
you are today I know you were kind of
doing maybe like indie work it seems
like er independent stuff so what was
that moment when did it click that hey
what I'm trying to do maybe I could just
do it on YouTube instead No and because
I think a lot of filmmakers are looking
like they have similar aspirations to
you well it's you know you have to give
people credit and that they're only
working kind of out a 20th century model
I was aspiring like I always have my
head I'm gonna make this cool indie
breakout film that's gonna be like a
cult classic and that would be my
calling card and that would lead to
other stuff and you know I would make
the movie or I would make shorts and
then I attempted a feature and I would
submit it to festivals and nobody would
watch because nobody was coming to the
festivals to watch it and nobody knew
who I was and nobody cared and the
quality of the product wasn't that good
it was you know every filmmakers first
film has got issues with it you know
technically speaking and I put my heart
and my soul into these short films and
these indie films and it wasn't
happening I couldn't get people watching
it because I was kind of in this box or
I was actually a better metaphor would
be I was just kind of shouting into the
void and I eventually got to the point
where I realized so everybody is online
everybody's watching youtube videos why
don't I just start why don't I shift my
focus why don't I stop trying to be the
breakout indie movie star and just try
and tell interesting or cool stories on
YouTube what we're like maybe you're one
or two first successes where people
noticed out this Austin McConnell guy
has something to say so the first video
that I made was an essay about the book
Harry Potter and cursed the cursed child
screenplay and when I released that that
was sort of my first jump into
you know trying to do trying to do
something up long form critical analysis
whatever I thought I would try that and
I released it and you know it had a
thousand views after three months of
being out there and then I sort of
slowly watched it get 100 views a day
until it finally hit 10,000 and once it
hit 10,000 something about hitting
10,000 I wait woke up the next morning
the light went on it was at 35,000 the
next morning and then the next day was
like 60,000 and within like 2 weeks it
was getting hundreds of thousands of
views and I was like okay this is kind
of really interesting and I actually
took a screenshot on my phone of the
video when it had like 100,000 hits and
I said man this is as good as it's gonna
get I'm gonna commemorate this occasion
with a screenshot and I had some other
stuff as I work I was working on and so
I was releasing more videos alongside it
and eventually it just slowly but surely
that snowball formed and then it just
kind of started rolling organically and
then I started getting to the situation
where I would release videos and I could
tell that I had a consistent immediate
audience and at that point I was like
okay I now have people who are watching
the stuff that I'm producing it wasn't
the stuff I thought that I would have
people watching but the trick now that
I'm going to try and pull is now that I
have an audience let me go back and let
me actually make an indie film now that
folks are watching
I'm glad you said that because there's a
movie that ok you may or may not be
producing you hinted at it I'm goofy
that I may or may know that in one of
your videos yeah didn't want me to it's
a right I'm proud of that and you told
me you can't talk about it yeah let's
talk about ok what can you tell us about
this super secret super awesome project
the gorge did you say super secret super
super austin oh it's like what does that
mean never I do clever right
I can't say anything about it honestly
because if I reveal if I say information
about it right now and it changes then
I'll have either lied to people or I'll
have set up a false expectation and it's
in its in pre-production right now we're
heading towards production next year and
you know details change especially an
indie film stuff changes sometimes
last-minute and right now it's you know
stories in a pretty locked-in state
right now we're just kind of looking at
the practical feasibility you know the
one thing is that now that I've found
success on YouTube and I've been able to
turn this into a career I'm now able to
facilitate a budget to shoot on that was
way beyond what I ever thought possible
and I'm able to take that and like I can
invest that back into now making it you
know making it you know a serious film
you know this is my the way I kind of
keeps saying it to myself is this is
sort of my next year when I when I make
this thing it's gonna be sort of my last
big shot are you gonna take a hiatus
from you to what you do are you gonna
that just sounds like so much work I'm
tired just hear that well I mean I
wouldn't - I won't take a hiatus from
YouTube I might reduce it I might go to
Beyer bimonthly but but this is gonna be
a huge departure from probably what a
lot of your fans know you as yeah it
which is what's interesting about your
work though is story and I may have
talked to you a little bit about this
earlier jewelry is a really integral
component of the kinds of things that
you make yeah it's not just about like
for example your ink cartridges video
it's not just about it being a scam it's
about the story of you going over to
your grandma's house I think yeah and
and how that all unfold is really
interesting and it's one of the great
lessons of screenwriting is that story
is the best way to talk about facts and
it's actually one of the most
interesting things period yeah well that
video actually starts off the intro tag
on it is I think it's like exterior
Austin's garage day like it's set up as
if it's us right so you kind of already
are that but still this movie is gonna
be a well every video I make is a short
film
in some way shape or form I'm telling a
story about something and it's
structured as if it's a short film that
has a definitive beginning middle and
end but in terms of going to the
narrative way it's gonna be a little bit
it's it's interesting it's gonna be
different for people to see a narrative
it's a narrative something that I'm
telling which is strange because where I
come from in Springfield Missouri that
was all I was known for was making these
narrative shorts that were kind of you
know dark and and you know interesting
to watch really kind of strange and
depressed I think things like that and
so that was always known for but now I'm
at this situation where me way more
people now know me for the goofy KFC we
are we were and so but at the same time
I'm not am I yeah what am i at the same
time one of my more highly appreciated
videos on my channel it's close to my
heart and lots of people's hearts
because I get way more emails from
people telling me about what they
thought about that was the video where I
talked about is the retrospective of the
first film I shot and that's like my
channel trailer right now it's a 33
minute video where I'm just talking
about what I learned from shooting my
first feature film I went into shooting
this film with you know this huge
expectation of it being this big thing
and it was just a complete failure in
every way but having some time removed
from it and learning going through the
process of shooting it I was able to
make a youtube video about my experience
shooting it and that retrospective about
the making of the movie is way more
successful than the movie ever was and
that's just kind of the way that it is
on YouTube now so I think that people
sort of know that I do a little bit of
filmmaking it's just that they've never
had at the big the business card films
right right I think um I think that's
very true and I'm really excited to see
it I wish you wouldn't I don't have any
details to you know what genre it is no
I'm not going to tell you that because I
don't that's fair the films that I write
aren't genre films
I say that like I feel like what I just
said who's gonna be replayed 20 years
from now when I become this like renown
and I you know stuff is fluid and stuff
changes and I don't want to I feel
sometimes like it's like the emperor has
no clothes like the fact that I'm saying
very little about it is hyping it way
more than if I say so one of my favorite
things about your channel is you're not
afraid to like talk about failure yeah
it's like the central thing it it I love
it because a lot of people try to just
kind of cover their you know their past
failures and pretend like oh I was
always this talented are always always
good and one of my favorite things is
you confront that directly I think
you've had a channel for how long 12
years so a lot longer than most you've
had a channel a lot longer than most
other youtubers yeah and and only
recently have you found kind of some
sure footing yeah like Laura a half ago
two years maybe I think that that that
whole concept of artistic failure being
a component of success it's something
that if you don't properly understand
that you're not going to be equipped
kind of weather the storm so to speak
you might have a few failures and you
think oh this is just this just means
I'm bad
yeah I'm whatever but of course when you
when you do find success like you didn't
you can just look back and be like oh no
that was just all building to my future
success what do you think was your your
failure that you took the hardest at the
time and was like later on you thought
oh no this was totally wrong
was it your film speaking in terms of
filmmaking you know there's plenty
personal factors but it's thinking in
terms of filmmaking I think it was the
fact that I think it was the film when I
started shooting sprouting orchids I was
a very pretentious young man who thought
that he was the next da Vinci
was gonna like make this masterpiece
thing from nothing and I was just way in
over my head and I thought way too
highly of myself and I was very prideful
and it was a very humbling experience to
fail and to be the direct result of the
failure itself and to not be able to
blame it on others and so you know it
was a very humbling experience to me in
that respect and I think maybe that's
resonated with people now on YouTube
because I'm much more open and honest I
don't try and pretend like I'm this big
fancy I'm just some I'm just some dude
in southwestern Missouri trying to make
cool stuff like I'm not that big of a
deal and so I try to I try to reflect
that in what I do right now I just make
goofy videos every now and then and
sometimes if I have something profound
to say I'll say it and I think one of
the things that has really helped is
that I want to focus on telling other
people who are interested in the kind of
stuff that I'm interested in that they
if I can do this kind of stuff then they
can at least have a shot at it I love
that one am I so this is maybe the other
so your channel is very miscellaneous
and I think the other maybe through line
of your channel is that you you are
actively trying to prop other smaller
channels up and like you said give
people chances maybe they wouldn't have
otherwise but you only pick five and you
pick them on like the category of
quantity quality are there any people
that you thought man I wish I could shut
them out they either have a little over
a thousand yeah they have like one
thousand and two or something like that
like did you ever think like oh I wish I
could give this person a voice not
really because I mean if they're above
1,000 then they are starting to form at
the very least their own audience and
maybe it's somebody who's got 13,000
subscribers they're not huge but they've
got their own little you know their
thing that's growing and at that point I
just directly collaborate with them so
let me ask you this who's your favorite
small creator ooh now that's a great
question who's my favorite small creator
if I had my phone I would be able to
like look at
here's like this floating hand is going
to come off screen Thanks it's the
production it's the high production you
know it's interesting is one of the
great things about YouTube is that I say
to myself this is a great small creator
that maybe I should reach out to and by
the time I check the numbers again
they've grown to the point where they're
even you know no longer small they're no
longer a small creator let me look at my
subscriptions here um let me see here no
he's at 30 and he's at 50 okay so
there's two well let me just talk about
one for brevity's sake and so I gave
this guy a shout-out in my last at
my last what's what's going on here
sorry so I give this guy a shout out in
the last the last video I did on
creators was under 1000 I was a channel
aspect science yet under thousand
subscribers I was looking at the stuff
was that this guy's got some great
editing skills he's got a great
on-camera personality he's gonna go far
and he just kind of needs that kick you
know yeah or just a little bit of hey
check this guy out and if even a
fraction of my audience checked him out
then it would just cause some kind of a
chain reaction and like within a day he
had 15,000 subscribers and like today he
was featured as artists on the rise a
creator on the rise on YouTube and he's
just gonna you know if he stays with it
he's just gonna launch and do his own
thing I hope he gets bigger than I am I
hope that everybody that I shout out in
that series becomes a much bigger
YouTube than me and I think that's the
perfect example of giving just someone a
helping hand like a science the like
poster Joe artists on the rise they're
given all these opportunities that they
would have never otherwise gotten now I
want to shift a little bit to kind of
you you've had a lot of a lot of success
and I think you're at six hundred
thousands plus 650 yourself I think that
was the last I checked it's interesting
when you start out you're kind of you're
kind of a nobody and then you build up
and then eventually you're somebody and
before it maybe you make videos on
somebody else and then people start to
make videos on you and so you made a
video called wind card games break oh
yeah where you got a lot
oh I can't wait that is where a lot of
people gave you a lot of light I got
more hate than when I said I liked the
last Jedi you guys when I saw the
comments in that video I was like
shocked oh yes quite volatile I think
you made just the technical error on
like one of the I didn't explain one of
the game mechanics because I'm just I'm
dumb I don't I don't know like I'm I
played the game casually and I didn't
understand the mechanics of one of the
things I said that a certain card could
create an infinite loop and the way I
described how that happens is not
exactly how it happens and I I kind of
as my wife told me I I poked the
hornet's nest of the hearthstone gaming
community and boy did they let me know
it it was it was a fun three days of
kind of way over the top it started off
with hey you got this technically wrong
and then it devolved into we're gonna
send death threats to you and your
friends and I still to this day have
people comment on other videos like I
will release a video this Wednesday and
I think guarantee you that there will be
a small section of the comments saying I
just can't listen to anything you say
ever since you messed up at hearthstone
video and if that's true then I'm very
sorry that's just it's weird how fickle
kind of well you know people are very
dedicated to their thing that's their
game that's their community and people
will take it as a personal attack
if you say something incorrectly or you
attempt to say something negative about
it and the fact that I had incorrectly
explained a mechanic gave sort of a
scapegoat to write off the actual point
of the video which was the fact that we
now live in a in a we live in a gaming
environment where games are routinely
patched
and altered after you purchased and the
whole point of the video was that you
know we we live in this place where you
pay for a certain product or gaming
experience and then the designer of the
game can decide to alter that experience
after you purchased the game a few years
ago if you went you bought Goldeneye
double-oh-seven for the n64 that was it
that was the game and you knew what
you're paying for and that was the
experience but now you can buy a game
like no man's sky that is a certain type
of game and then a year later it is
completely different sometimes that's a
very good thing in the instance of no
man's sky but in other situations it's
and the whole point was that I started
the video off talking about card games
as a kid that I would play at the middle
school cafeteria i watch middle
schoolers play in the cafeteria and how
the the card game world has shifted at
all I'm it's regrettable that that
legitimate point was lost in the fact
that I I was just dumb and poorly
explained in mechanic's and it had to
devolve into the to the bashing what I
thought was interesting is it seemed
like almost due to your and this is what
I meant by you'd grow into a big
youtuber I think when you're when you're
smaller youtuber and you make a mistake
like that it's forgivable let you know
it's nothing it's forgivable it's that
you can't get anywhere by calling them
out yeah and I think because you were
big at that point and the video kind of
went viral
I saw people making entire videos using
yeah they have my faces the thumbnail
with liar and fraud because I didn't
understand how to play a card game
correctly yeah I don't want to be like
I'm not selling government secrets to
you know a foreign agent or something
I'm just getting a a game mechanic wrong
I'm sorry
I'm did like people assign ill-will to
you you don't you don't even play the
game that's all fake footage that you
didn't even record you stole somebody
else's footage and pretended you don't
even play hearthstone couldn't it just
be that I'm just a casual player and I
just did misunderstood the mechanic and
that that's one of the points of the
video is that it's it causes casual
players to want to give up on the
so I have sorry I don't know I don't
want to get it no it's like it's why I
have like a segue into my own experience
when I was starting out I like did a
kind of similar thing where I was on the
other side I was like calling out
somebody else yeah I've just like
philosophy channels okay and looking
back on it did you threaten to like no
no no no but yeah but I think but I
think what happens is when people see
someone successful and if the person
successful makes like a mistake they
assume everything that person is doing
is probably a mistake and they've kind
of you know brought these sheeple in
into their you know your locker room and
it's easy to kind of pick them out and
criticize them because honestly when you
get bigger you're actually an easier
target yeah who's your target to make
fun of because you have this dedicated
fan base and dedicated fan bases are
always easy to make fun of him so I just
thought that dynamic was interesting of
when it happened to you was very telling
of like the kind of attention it was
mm-hmm
not that it wasn't right about the
specifics of the game mechanic but the
backlash was so extreme you know that I
think it maybe showed that there was I
think some people were trying to get
some people not everybody but some
people were trying to get a video out of
it yeah well I mean when you create a
video that's like got my face on it with
like liar and fraud and it's like just
you know the trash here you are towards
someone the more clicks you're going to
get in some instances and if people
wanted like if people want to choose
that hill to kill me on then you know
it's it's whatever they it's whatever
they want to do but the great thing
about all of this is that I've tried to
be smart and surround myself with actual
friends and family who are supportive
and you know I don't I don't live and
die by weather run named idiot or
warriors like me or not I I get to go
home every day and my wife that loves me
and we've got a wonderful relationship
and that's I'm happy with that I can be
with that if people want to be mad at me
about a Miss stated because I didn't
understand a card game yeah okay that's
awesome and and as I built my you to kid
I've looked back that'll be enough oh
yeah well they because you become the
creator because I've become the creator
with flaws it's not that my criticisms
were technically wrong yeah but it's
like it's like you don't give these
larger creators any kind of like well
you don't view them as a person yeah you
don't give them any like like oh they
have a limited budget a limited time to
do the research etc so definitely I kind
of stepped into the shoes a little bit
and realized yeah the kind of pitfalls
being creators it's tough I mean
especially when you do like educational
content or you do factual content like
video essays I get like three things
wrong in every video I mean if you want
a list of the stuff that I've stated
wrong I should even do a video about all
of the factual inaccuracies you don't
have this cuz I'm just I'm just like I
said just subdued just already making
videos and I'm gonna make mistakes I'm
gonna say something wrong every now and
then I'm gonna incorrectly stated a few
facts sometimes it's like because I
didn't really understand it properly
sometimes it's because when I was
recording it I said the wrong number
yeah and I didn't catch it by the time I
edited it and sent it out there because
when you're just kind of DIY anything
and you're yourself and the other thing
is sometimes the stuff that I study are
the information that I look at is
actually not accurate or in the case of
certain things it becomes dated over
time and you know it's this it's one of
the pitfalls the creator of being a
creator it goes with the territory you
have to learn to not live and die by
whether people are going to click
subscribe or click thumbs up and if I
get something wrong one week you're just
gonna have to you just have to bear with
me forgive me come back next week and if
you decide you don't like it then stop
watching that's fine and you know all I
can do is try and do my best and it's
not gonna be perfect by any means but it
is true that once you become a creator
and once you actually start having no
once you've got this you're wearing
those shoes then
when people start sending you
ridiculously over-the-top hateful
messages and like literal physical
threats you go this person just doesn't
even realize that they're not viewing
you as a human being at that point like
they would never say those things to me
nice nice and if they did they would
like immediately nobody would listen to
them but you know that's just you know
that's just but I will say that the
Internet's been around long enough now
and it's old enough to where trolls are
something you can kind of write off and
it they just don't take it too
personally
so turning from that to turning from
that video to another video that you did
that I that I really enjoy actually like
the card game I like your overall point
which was funny because then I scrolled
down and I saw like the explosion in the
comments but yeah another video that I
really liked of yours was the video
about books we didn't like a book review
and specifically I loved this idea that
you present which is that you've got to
get out of the hive mind which is your
point was is you brought up a book like
you said you know you've got to get out
there and read because the internet just
says the same thing to each other all
the time
yeah and the only way you're gonna get
new information in your head is by or
information that isn't in everyone
else's head yeah is by reading something
else and you said not this book and I
think you flash turtles all the way down
not because it's john green's book but
because everybody's reading john well
for a long I'm willing to surmise that
for many people that was the only book
they read they here maybe the past three
years so to you how do you get how do
you break out of that loop because I
think for a lot of people when they
think of selecting a book they just want
to go to Barnes & Noble and it's or some
book store and they're looking at the
shelves and it's overwhelming how do you
find interesting unique like books
because there's so many you don't want
to read trash you know it makes sense
that you'd go to the top place and you
just see what's worth reading yeah and
then that's how everyone ends up reading
the same thing so I agree with your
point that we need to kind of it's more
interesting when we're all reading
different things but to your point how
do we so you just go to a library and
you go to a section that you would never
be caught dead end you close your eyes
and you spin around and whatever your
fingers pointing at whichever book on
the Shelf you take it off and you check
it out and you read it that's it it's
funny alright well the thing is you you
give yourself that element of random
circumstance yeah I thought biographies
and like nonfiction stuff was so boring
growing up we couldn't get into it I was
all about fantasy novels and now like
90% of well maybe not 90% but a large
portion of what I read her biography is
because I just started reading them and
about fascinating people and they had
you know interesting lives and I think
probably another portion of that is the
fact that I'm getting older and tastes
change as you get older and they you
tend to shift towards other things and
so in terms of like video the whole
point I was kind of making that video of
getting outside the hive mind
specifically for video essays I've
noticed that a lot of video essayists
watch me I think somebody told me one
time that I was like the video essayists
video essay or whatever that means
that's something like that so how should
I say this look David Fincher's a great
director and he's makes great stuff and
I don't want to deny any of that at all
but it can only have so many takes on
him and somebody takes on his work and
he's not the only director and there
have been directors that have been dead
for 30 years now who made some amazing
films way back when that nobody watches
anymore and there are some lessons to be
learned the stuff they made as well and
there are a lot of great directors that
you know haven't gotten any airtime at
the play time that you could probably
look at I think maybe part of the reason
that people make videos about that is
because number one everyone talks about
them yeah it's easy it's easy the other
reason I think
is that they think well what are people
interested in and they see what are
people watching so sometimes it's an
it's like you're scared to become too
obscure you know you're like way out in
the weeds yeah I was interested but
other times if you can do it right you
can turn an obscure film into like a
really interesting thing about a passion
thing that you love yeah and I mean the
amount of dark night but usa's I've seen
yeah hurts my brain but I see why people
pick it as a car because everybody
everybody loves marble yeah everybody
you know and so and then there's this
whole like meta of like now Fox is
saying why Marvel is overrated yeah
everyone makes so many so but they're
still making a video I'd say about
Marvel everybody's happy so how do sorry
you were actually I think you were
talking about I don't want to cut off
your point I think you're talking about
how we get out of that so you're saying
everybody does
David Fincher everyone does Marvel The
Dark Knight you're saying do it
differently well let me let me maybe put
it like that I like this I understand
that having a video about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe was gonna get clicks
I get that I understand I'm having two
Star Wars videos probably gonna get
clicks I understand that and I get that
so maybe instead of focusing exclusively
on that you do your tentpole video that
covers the top of the popular film of
the day but have some supplemental
material where you're investigating
obscure artists or film directors who
have not been if you want to stay in the
zeitgeist if you want to sound
pretentious about it you know obscure
folks that aren't being talked about
right now do that in addition to that
step I did this video on a short and a
short film animator named Jonathan job
and condo in France and he makes these
amazing minimalistic animated films and
so I was watching this stuff I was it
this is amazing this guy's got this
it's great great animation great and
unlike anything else and nobody's
talking about it so I'll just make a
video about it and so I make a video
about it and it wasn't this huge viral
breakout hit but it got a substantial
amount of views and there comes an email
in my inbox and it's him and he's like
hey I just watched this video thank you
thank you very very much people are
watching the stuff that I'm making and
it's encouraged me as you create and you
start making more stuff that's that's
the best feeling in the world
you know it's like a you know all these
bands that got real popular way back
when it was they didn't have you know it
was word of mouth and you can't spread
new stuff by word of mouth if nobody's
watching different stuff you know
there's again I don't have a problem
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe think
the great films I don't have problem
with David Fincher's director I think
they're great films it's just you know
if you want to advance the art form you
you need to kind of talk about some new
stuff it's definitely a meme kind of in
the video essay community that video
essay is almost exclusively do film
analysis yeah which is something that I
think I'm a big fan of us eventually
outgrowing like you said I don't have a
family people doing film analysis
yeah but I'd like to see I'd like to see
that genre and encompass more than just
film analysis well because there's so
much to talk about yeah I think that
there's a few reasons why video essay
seemed to primarily be film analysis one
reason might be because it's easier to
produce because you're the film has
already been shot you're just sourcing
put it and it's great yeah it's visual
people everybody's watched it there's
that pre-established knowledgebase about
the film in question the way that I see
video is say is continuing or evolving
over time is that you branch out and
talk about things outside of film you
know video essayist exists and they
existed before YouTube they would just
call a documentary films
and so that's the direction it's going I
mean you have half of your videos that
you make can be expanded to 30 or 40
minutes and you could make a film you'll
make a documentary about it it's just
that the medium now favors online video
and that's that's the form that it'll
take one of the things I think is most
interesting and unique about your
channels kind of value is that you come
from that film background and it really
shows in your work like I said it shows
in your storytelling
what's something I think a lot of people
who watch this channel are either
interested in filmmaking filmmakers
themselves or interested in the people
who do filmmaking so I want to ask kind
of a question about YouTube youtuber
creation in general what's the thing you
think is overlooked the most by creators
who obviously they're just DIY which
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that I'm DIY but something that we're
just missing that is kind of a
fundamental to screenplays or
screenwriting that could be easily fixed
whether it's tech whether it's camera
stuff whether it's writing what do you
think something that like you
consistently think I have an edge
because I know this that's a good
question I think a willingness to tread
untraveled ground when I do videos where
I try and highlight small creators and I
and I ask people to give me
recommendations it's usually like kids
trying to promote their for tonight
gameplay channel or it's somebody trying
to be the second-rate version of a
different creator and I think that's
born out of a few things but ultimately
I think the biggest reason is because
that's proven ground
and you see that somebody out there is
having success covering a certain
subject or a certain topic or a certain
type of video and so people think I'm
going to do that myself
and as a result of that you have a bunch
of people poorly imitating someone who's
already doing it way better than anybody
else and it takes a little bit of
courage to try something that hasn't
been done before or experiment or go
outside the established wheelhouse but I
think that there are benefits to be had
and if you're gonna gonna create stuff
why not why not try and create something
that somebody else isn't already doing I
think this point is like absolutely huge
no millionaire has ever become a
millionaire by reading someone else's
how I became a millionaire book yeah
because that's outdated information yeah
you know and they took advantage of an
arc adopted it's survivor bias yeah
you've got your god bless people like I
don't want to name any names because I
don't want to start any beast but you've
got these creators who are like hey look
just do this that and give it your all
and it'll be great and it's like well
there were a ton of factors right it
caused you to be the success that you
are that were way out of your control
and once they're - it's so much less
interesting yeah when like Casey nice
that did his little vlog thing other be
blood Don vlogs he kind of
revolutionized it in a way yeah and then
you saw everyone carrying around the
same gorilla try pet pod you're the same
set up you know and they're doing the
same like jump cuts and if it's if it's
I mean it's not that you can't do the
vlog a different way you can but
everyone is doing it the same way a lot
of people are and I think that's huge
I think realizing that they didn't find
success by that formula they found that
success by finding a formula that was
different
mm-hmm and that if you're copying it
you're no longer different you're no
longer you no longer have the thing that
they had that made them success
which we know they were the first well
one of the reasons why he's been so
successful is because what he does on
the day-to-day is specifically conducive
to that blog format and not everybody
has an extravagant to life as he does
and why would you have I don't want to
be critical when I say this but why
would you want to be a second-rate kc
nice tat when you could be the
first-rate version of yourself so it
makes sense
maybe you think the second rape version
of Casey Neistat well I mean if I want
it yeah if you want to be if you think
the second-rate version of Casey Knights
that is way better than the first great
version of yourself then now get to get
to know yourself a little bit better I
mean go go like so if I had started
doing YouTube two years ago or three
years ago let me rephrase that if I had
tried if I had given myself from three
years ago the job that I have right now
with YouTube I would have washed out on
week one because a lot of what I'm able
to do right now I had to learn through
failure for those three years in order
to be able to handle the responsibility
that comes with creating this stuff that
I create and you
you shouldn't want to you see let me
restart this you shouldn't want to I
understand the imitation is the
sincerest form of flattery and everybody
pays homage in some way shape or form
there are creators that I live things
from every now and then because they've
been an influence to me but you've got
to create something that it is that
comes from you
and if you're putting on a facade we're
trying to be like somebody else buying
all the same equipment buying all the
same toys that they play with having the
same style of editing using the same
font that they use and the same type of
cuts and people people don't want to
watch a guy play direct play dress up as
Casey Neistat at like is like do that
like what other successful youtuber is
doing like it's just I don't you
wouldn't create like all these TV shows
you see on on TV people still what do
you do well you wouldn't create a
knockoff you might well look if somebody
can create a knockoff Harry Potter but
it's not gonna be Harry Potter right
they're just gonna go watch Harry Potter
yeah and you would to like I don't know
right
no it's thinking out loud and again you
know sometimes I feel like a hypocrite
when I say things like that because
there are times where when I create
stuff I'm influenced by things that I
watch oh you've got a big forgiveness to
whoever you gotta beg forgiveness to for
that but at the same time you've got to
be aiming towards your you know your
unique perspective
cool I think we're gonna get to the this
is like scrolling through gotta get to
my questions I got it to get to my
questions I don't my glasses on so I
can't read any of that perfect perfect
you don't know what's next I want to get
to a sort of we'll call it a lightning
round
just kind of lightning quick answers to
some some questions I don't know I don't
know if I can give quick answers but if
you that's okay let me preface by saying
that what I say in this lightning round
might not actually be an accurate
representation of what I truly think
sure but what is an idea or framework
that you have that you think more people
should carry around with them repeat
that one more time what is an idea or
like a framework of thinking that you
have that you think more people should
carry around before you post or click
upload or click publish ask yourself one
question why would anybody even watch
this do you have any weird hobbies that
people don't know about um any weird
hobbies that people don't know about and
the only thing anything it was like well
I do YouTube that's a weird hobby let's
see here I am a huge Kansas City Chiefs
fan all about the Chiefs I don't think
many people know that well there ya see
what would baby what would you do
they're gonna be like 6 and 13 but
seriously it's not even possible
but they'll pull it off let's finish
what would you do if you weren't doing
filmmaking or YouTube what I do if I
wasn't doing filmmaking your YouTube I
would probably be exercising my
creativity and a different art form this
is gonna I know this is lightning round
but let me go back to this if you're
looking for inspiration and you want to
do something that's different and
outside of the hive line go to an art
gallery and just walk around unless
you'll find inspiration or oh sorry
lightning rod go go go go breaking the
rules what is the video that you thought
would make you've always wanted to make
I never had the courage to mmm never had
the courage to you that can mean either
that you didn't think it would be
publicly successful you don't want to
risk it or it can mean literally that
you were didn't want to like there's
some there's some it's not so much me
putting my neck out of putting the necks
of others out there's some personal
things that have gone on in my life that
have been not so pleasant but have truly
defined Who I am today but if I were to
tell those stories than the people
involved would be truly hurt and truly
affected by it and so you know as with
all things in life you there are certain
things there are certain cards you play
closer to your chest and I don't know
that it would be an appropriate Avenue
to especially now when I know that
several 100,000 people are going to be
hearing my very flawed side of something
that might have happened
it's not fair to abuse the position that
I'm in in such a way but maybe years
from now when I'm like reflecting on my
life if I don't know that if I have a
lot of years left then maybe I can write
something about you know the personal
side they're not so happy stuff and you
know or maybe it'll just be personal you
know when you write about personal stuff
you can kind of reflect on things and
gain some credit perspective so anyway
so the more the less happy side of the
personal stuff yeah I understand that
you're Christian yeah what role does
that play in your day-to-day life
what role does faith play
um I wouldn't even I wouldn't phrase it
as what rule does it play in my life it
defines everything about my life and the
faith that I have took me out of a very
dark and destructive place and put me
back up and gave me a second chance at
everything and so it's not so much what
role does it play in life it's what
defines everything about it if you take
it out and the entire structure
collapses that makes sense but there's a
hard left turn okay sorry that was a
dependent okay sorry I appreciate well
you're asking about religion and it has
their deep questions that require deep
answer I shouldn't I should have put
that before the lightning right I'm sure
what is the most popular book
recommendation that you make to people
where they say hey I want a great book
that I've never heard of before or I've
made probably never have run across you
can do fiction or nonfiction or you want
or you can just recommend one okay so if
someone's are creative and they want to
be they want to get in the movies or
they wanted to get into writing and they
ask what should I read read Stephen
King's on writing I love that book yep
it's a tremendous tremendous book yeah
what about fiction specifically now
that's a hard question I have to ask
them I'm a fiction head so I'm I'm a big
fan you just asking for a good fiction
book recommendation what do you have a
go-to
you know it sounds strange but the
original Harry Potter run is pretty good
it's a you know especially for a certain
age tell us tell us a complete story and
those books don't get as much of a I
don't like the direction that the
franchise has gone in recently but I do
appreciate that
if you view that core series by itself
it's a great complete story I say that
because my wife recently read all of
them for the first time and it was fun
to sort of revisit that point in my
childhood might be nostalgia talking but
good world building and then I guess
this is probably gonna be one of the
last questions I love really weird
history the series you do you're the
only guy no I think that's a tremendous
series yeah um where do you find those
stories generally in history books so
you'd like to really go through it I
don't I've never read those in history
book
yeah no you just read weird oddball
history facts when I was a kid I think
I've hooked up picked up at a book fair
at school weird history facts and stuff
and I read no like no obscure
presidential trivia and things like that
I you know really weird history kind of
broke my heart that was you know I
really loved that series and it was not
nearly as successful as I thought it
would be I plan to do seven episodes
simply got three in and it was just not
the amount of time it took to produce
the episodes now you can do Saadian
scoff sure if you haven't watched really
weird history go right now share it with
your friends
I recommend the Americas Emperor or it's
the American Emperor the America Emperor
the United States Emperor of the United
States incredible operation mincemeat is
my second favorite yeah go watch it we
got to get this thing back back on track
cuz we're what I mean that was one of my
favorite things that I've made and just
nobody watched it and the people who
watch it didn't seem to
I don't know what happened with it
honestly it might have just been that I
was not advertising it correctly
maybe I didn't you know brand it
correctly whatever that means
I have submitted those as short films to
festivals and so they'll play on a
festival circuit but yeah it was just I
loved making them and I loved the end
result of all of them I liked what we
made I think that maybe if it doesn't
have it have a place on YouTube maybe it
will thrive in some other form or some
other medium the book boy they took a
long time to make those I mean it was
tough well but the strange thing about
this is that the one the one analytic
you don't get with YouTube is impact and
those videos like once I saw those I was
like oh man I'm a huge fan I know the
fan but I was like oh this is great
content Wow so to me some sometimes the
smaller videos you can make yeah and
it's hard to see as a creator but from
an audience it's obvious some of the
smaller films you do even though they
might not be like commercially
successful you could get yourself a fan
for life you know so I I understand if I
can if if I could if I could do it I
would go back and do more of those
because there are plenty of stories to
tell histories and listen that way but
you know when it's a two and a half
month production cycle I put one of
those together we're animating 100% of
it and voicing an audio mixing and all
of that it's just I've worked my work
more on really weird history to perfect
those videos than probably any other
video that I made and I loved it because
it was a form of narrative yes that's
right that's what I one of my favorite
parts too awesome
well it's just imagine what I could do
if I had a feature yes yes there are
stories left to tell us you have it tell
us what your features well I'll say this
there are lots of stories that I'm
burning to tell and I've been very
grateful and appreciative that people
have been listening the past few months
last year and a half I hope they
continue to listen I'm going to continue
to try and
say things that are worth hearing and if
folks folks want to follow along that's
great I'll do my best to make the
stories I have to tell worthwhile if not
I don't really care all right awesome
thanks thanks man McConnell for coming
on that coffee width episode this is Ben
coffee with episode 2 hang on women it's
done on three one two three that's how
we ended things love it
[Music]